welcome to database def Talk I'm your
host - cozy our today's guest is Sara
Lou Sara lives in Toronto Canada and
attends McMaster University
there she is working towards a Bachelor
of Commerce majoring in marketing
Sarah is also one of the winners of the
visualized 2030 contest which serves
love for animals and passion for the
environment she was excited to create a
visual story that would drive awareness
to these important causes Sarah welcome
to the show thank you so tell audience
about a little bit about yourself what
are you busy with these days yeah so I'm
currently a commerce student at McMaster
University and I am currently on
internships so I will be returning to
school for my last year in the fall once
I graduate I'll hopefully be looking to
start my career in something in
marketing or maybe something in the
digital space so how do you become
interested in data visualization in the
first place so at my organization
currently where I'm interning I have had
a couple of opportunities to create
different dashboards using data studio
so for instance a sales performance
dashboard and a dashboard on seeing
where our leaves are coming from so that
is what forced me to learn more about
data visualization but also we
collectively as an organization we
occasionally do data visualization for
fun and to practice their skills so
being able to see other people's more
creative works of data visualization is
what really got me excited to try it
myself as I like creating things that
are visually appealing and funny to look
at so that was what really excited me to
learn more what has been your experience
with data studio you mentioned that the
organization you're working at that's
where you've got to introduce you the
tool but as you've used it more and more
would you think about it what has been
your overall experience with this yeah
so data studio is a great tool it's
basically the only data visualization
tool that I use because it's so simple
to use and it's really easy to get
started and
do you really just get this blank canvas
and you can go wherever you want you can
make something very simple and plain and
just get right to the point or you can
do something completely different and
creative and turn it into like kind of
like a piece of art but also showing
data so that's what I really love and
like I said with drag-and-drop features
and different filtering options you can
really completely transform a basic
chart into something that's interactive
and something that just kind of goes
with the flow of what you're trying to
tell in your narrative Congrats on being
world to five winners of double utilize
twenty thirty contest thank ya can you
take the audience through the
visualization that you've built like
tell them about the true story that
you're trying to tell twelve this entire
dashboard yeah so let's go ahead and get
into it and I can go through that so
here's my data visualization that I
submitted so I focused on a total of
four of the sustainable development
goals so I discussed how by achieving
the one goal one of the targets in the
zero hunger goal is to improve our
agricultural practices and make them
more sustainable
so by achieving this one we can work
towards three other goals of climate
action live on land and having clean
water and sanitation available to
everyone so as I was going through I
realized that agriculture doesn't just
affect the actual climate change but it
affects so many different things in our
environment so I wanted to display this
as a little road map that we can work
towards achieving these goals in a
future state and the different
roadblocks that are getting in the way
of actually achieving them so for
instance agricultural practices they
contribute to many greenhouse gas
emissions and we can see that they
increase over time and
in regards to livestock production in
particular as it increases around the
globe in every single in almost every
country we can see that there is a
positive correlation between livestock
production as well as the total
greenhouse gas emissions in her
atmosphere and when we focus on life on
land we can see that here in 1990 the
agricultural land in forest area were
almost equal in regards to arable land
but if we move to 2015 you can see that
there is a significant difference
between agricultural and forest area
land use and I focus in on some
different case studies to see how there
are different habitat losses because of
the land that is being used for
agricultural purposes rather than
forests and in regards to water
resources I focused on some different
case studies as well and how a majority
of water uses for certain countries are
used for agriculture even if they have
water stress already so at the end here
I just offered some different calls to
action on what we can do to achieve
these goals and by limiting our meat
consumption and using less land for
agriculture and less water for
agriculture we can really work towards
achieving all four of these goals in the
future what do you think about data
studio as a tool for anyone who's trying
to tell their own story and trying to
bring about social change yeah so like I
said because data studio is very easy to
get started with and it's also free to
use anyone especially if you're in a
non-profit or if you're doing a charity
you may not have the funds to invest in
a complex data visualization tool it
estudio allows anyone to learn more
about data visualization and to actually
put their data into visualization so I
think it's a great tool especially for
those purposes and because just data
visualization in general when you're
putting
into visual visuals it's very easy for
anyone to understand so you could
literally just have a chart and pretty
much anyone can look at a bar chart and
see that one is way bigger than another
and especially when it comes to things
like language barriers and just
different knowledge of understanding
when it comes to data this is a great
way to get your message out there to
everyone regardless of how familiar they
actually are with the data visualization
and it's also a great way to get your
story out there really quickly because
you can go from explaining in a
paragraph form of why this is that way
and that could take MIT like several
minutes or you could simply just glance
over at a chart and pull insights
instantly and data studio makes that
really easy to construct and get out
there and then again with the
interactive features that just makes it
so much it completely changes the
experience of the person who's viewing
the visualization whatever your advice
for folks who want to tell their own
data stories what kind of tips would you
give them yeah so I would say definitely
look at some other examples online to
get some inspiration on how you actually
want to construct your news story and
what's the best way to show what you're
trying to say but I would also say
rather than just copying something that
you see online definitely go into the
tool whether you're using data studio or
something else just go in there look at
the blank campus and play around with it
and see what it is you're trying to show
and really focus on what you're trying
to tell and you can really frame the
order of your story exactly in the story
that you're trying to tell so again when
you're going through and constructing
just think that you're telling a story
to someone that you know and construct
the visualization in that order so thank
you again for being on the show you can
learn more about the visualize 2030
contest and look at the winning
visualizations in the links in the
description for more data studio content
be sure to subscribe to the GCP channel
and you can always visit our site at
developers.google.com slash data studio
until next time keep building more viz
[Applause]